j'étais le premier blessé par les
lanceurs de balles de défense j'avais 16
ans voici pierre douillard membres de
l'assemblée des blessés un collectif de
victimes d'armes policière son histoire
commence en 2007 à nantes lors d'une
manifestation contre la loi pécresse
touché par un tir de flashball il perd
un oeil sa famille décide de porter
plainte
c'est passionnant c'est un prêche et ça
va créer un précédent cas en 2008 la
police des polices la firme
c'est cette arme qui est en cause le
lbd40 un flashmob nouvelle génération
plus précis que son prédécesseur mais
encore en phase d'expérimentation
les teintes franches et expérimentations
en ce moment dans des conditions très
discrète une arme qui est très
dangereuse et qui semble vraiment pas du
tout approprié au maintien de l'ordre
le lanceur de balles de défense est une
sorte de super flash-ball mais beaucoup
plus dangereux et qu'on utilise sur des
enfants
la plainte de la famille abouti à un
procès en mars 2012
quatre ans et demi après j'attends
qu'une chose de ce procès aujourd'hui
c'est savoir si la justice française
donne carte blanche à la police pour
mutiler des lycéens pour mutiler des
manifestants et pour mutiler des
citoyens appelés devant le tribunal
correctionnel de nantes l'agent qui a
tiré sur l'adolescent
d'après lé enquête il n'a fait
qu'exécuter des ordres de sa hiérarchie
à responsabilités ça n'est pas la sienne
c'est celle éventuellement de celui qui
a donné l'ordre
et cette responsabilité elle est
pleinement assumée par l'ensemble de sa
hiérarchie
et je vous rappelle qu'au plus haut
niveau de la police nationale tout le
monde à assumer cet ordre de tir le
policier relaxé mais la famille
douillard poursuit le combat judiciaire
déjà pour commencer en valais au
tribunal administratif on va attaquer
l'état on va attaquer la hiérarchie
policière au tribunal administratif la
famille douillard a obtenu une première
condamnation de l'état en 2016 et une
indemnisation de 48000 euros en première
instance
somme qui a doublé en appel
1018 en parallèle pierre douillard s'est
rapproché d'autres victimes présumées de
tirs de lanceurs de balles de défense
il met son expérience au profit des
procédures judiciaires d'autres blessés
il va falloir s'armer de patience il va
falloir créer dé devenir entre
guillemets des experts de ces armes là
et bien sûr il peut nous contacter pour
en savoir plus sur ces armes-là homos
[Musique]